le bistrot s'appelle le celtic
un nom qui fleure bon la bretagne et
pourtant dans ce bar tabac du quartier
populaire de belleville
le patron n'a rien d'un breton
il s'appelle patrick huard
il est d'origine chinoise est
aujourd'hui comme d'habitude il ne chôme
pas patrick vous arrivez à servir de
clients en même temps donc 3 3 l'octroi
de la vider la labilité c'est important
ah bah oui surtout ici certains ici oui
pourtant on a du monde si on est louable
soir patrick huard n'a racheté le bar il
ya maintenant sept ans comme beaucoup de
ses compatriotes il travaille en famille
pour l'aider au tabac il y à suzanne sa
grande soeur qui est arrivé en france en
même temps que lui il y a vingt ans mais
s'occuper du bar faire la conversation
avec les clients
ce n'est pas trop leur truc alors
patrick engagé deux personnes il y a
d'abord loulou originaires de chine
comme lui très à l'aise avec n'importe
quel client connaît je fais pas semblant
de travailler bonjour on se fait
engueuler par les clients voilà on
trouve tout le monde dans ce café on a
les cheveux noirs des maliens des arabes
des jeunes de ram et le mieux d'arabe
il reste encore quelques français
commandé et puis il ya aussi kamel le
tunisien bonjour cinq ans qu'il
travaille pour patrick et depuis il ne
tarit pas d'éloges sur les asiatiques
6 après très sensible et attentif
et puis dès qu'ils ont confiance en une
personne ça il se donne à fond et ça on
ne le voit pas ses cachets de travail
avec des hérétiques
on apprend plein de choses là oui on
l'apprend leur culture leur façon de
vivre leur heure la prop la de choses et
c'est bien mais que pensent les habitués
de ces patrons qui viennent d'ailleurs
il y a d'abord les éternels râleurs
avant c'était pas pareil par an ici les
arabes et les juifs lynx ap
à bernand s'échanger des chinois mais
pour beaucoup
passé l'effet de surprise ces nouveaux
patrons se sont avérés des gens bien
comme il faut
des lieux qui accueillent ans je suis
pas plus j'aime pas trop les bars tabacs
en principe mais là c'est
c'est sympathique les gens sont
ah c'est réglo assez réglo et même plus
que ça à la différence de beaucoup de
quartiers parisiens patrick cohen n'est
pas du genre à pousser les gens dehors
quand ils ont terminé leur verre à
squatter café pendant gbono 413 toujours
là on verrait tout le monde
ah ouais patrick huard le gentil patron
a été l'un des tout premiers chinois
reprendre un bistrot à paris et
aujourd'hui il est loin d'être le seul
car après avoir ouvert des boutiques
d'informatique des blanchisseries des
magasins de fruits et légumes
voilà que les chinois rachètent à tour
de bras les bar tabac pmu
le phénomène est visible dans toutes les
grandes villes et plus particulièrement
à paris comme ici aux kennedy juste en
face de la tour eiffel ou encore le
balto en plein centre de paris
quand ils sont vendus les cafés ne
change jamais de nom mais une fois sur
deux c'est un français d'origine
asiatique qui se retrouve derrière le
comptoir
une nouvelle donne qui ne plaît pas à
tout le monde
dans cette agence immobilière dominique
franco est aux premières loges de ses
transactions avec les chinois il s'est
spécialisé dans la revente de bistrot
parisien
merci au revoir
voilà alors là nous avons un tabac dans
le 14e
nous avons un tabac dans le 7e
arrondissement une petite brasserie dans
le 20e alors celle ci elle est un
compromis presque vendu j'ai lu j'ai des
clients de toute communauté
en ce moment j'ai des asiatiques
j'essaie aussi asiatiques
dominique franco devrait se réjouir de
l'apparition de ces nouveaux clients
sauf que ça lui pose un gros problème
il a parfois bien du mal à convaincre
les propriétaires de vendre à des
chinois comme le patron de cet
établissement
laurent ramé 25 ans de métier il a une
caractéristique très répandue dans le
milieu des bistrots il vient de
l'aveyron comme son garçon de café
d'ailleurs la vallée du lot les chemins
de saint jacques de compostelle à
espalion et raymonde à la montagne on
est voisins raymonde c'est la caissière
aveyronnaise aussi j'ai commencé
huit ans depuis cela rien d'étonnant à
paris les aveyronnais leur voisin
auvergnat avait encore récemment le
quasi monopole des établissements mais
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas ils
sont en train de se faire doubler par
une autre communauté en charge les
chinois vous avez reçu alors quand
dominique franco est sollicité par un
acheteur asiatique
bon ça a le don d'énerver notre patron
aveyronnais vous aller la visiter
d'accord à tout à tout à l'heure de
cette chambre non mais on préfère bord
dans les jambes chez nous que tu as des
gens de l'autre bout du monde
ce que moi je vais vous dire je suis
abonné et je re j'aime autant voilà
venir voir des amis je sais les
seigneurs de chez nous on a quelque
chose à partager on avait envie d'une
aide du même pays que une fois que
c'était nadia tic
on a on n'a plus les mêmes repères voilà
dans les affaires et puis si puis la
même culture
ah non non non attendez c'est le
principe du tous je m'appelle franco
belge peut pas être raciste
déjà moi je suis pas français je suis né
dans l'aveyron mais par l'ensemble des
adhérents miss irlande mes origines et 9
ans c'est une question de racisme c'est
une question de culture
la culture n'est pas la même qu'à peser
des asiatiques ça casse un petit peu
l'ambiance du bistrot le titre au
parisien alors si d'aventuré une
personne nazia tic qui a envie de
racheter le bistrot de cet aveyronnais
elle a intérêt à s'accrocher ça dépend
un peu plus un peu plus attendre pour ça
oui alors là tu as 30 % laura il faut
que tu partes
saler et de suite en réalité laurent ne
se fait aucune illusion il sait très
bien qu'il y a peu de chances qu'un
aveyronnais reprenne son affaire même
ses enfants n'ont pas envie de prendre
la suite
on regarde pas les heures un métier de
sacrifices les gens de chez nous vu la
nouvelle génération ne plus faire ce
métier là parce que
à trop de contrainte maintenant c'est un
marché qui est ouvert aux asiatiques et
aux maghrébins à d'autres communautés
que nos jeunes des conditions de travail
difficiles qui pourtant ne semble pas
rebuter les nombreux acquéreurs chinois
il est 7 heures du matin le quartier de
belleville à paris s'éveille à peine
mais le bistrot de patrick huard est
déjà ouvert le patron a du pain sur la
planche
direction le fond de sa cave
il doit ranger sa livraison de tama du
matin contre la commande et la livraison
il faut 5 6 heures c'est trop trop trop
dit aucun boulot 7 sur 7 16 heures par
jour un travail difficile mais qui ne
nécessite pas de qualification
particulière et qui au final rapporte le
plus rentable c'est le rayon tabac et
jeu patrick touche environ 50 centimes
par paquet de cigarettes et 2 % sur
chaque jeu de grattage à la fin du mois
quand il a payé ses charges et les
salaires de ses employés
il lui reste entre 2 et 3000 euros de
revenus et comme son affaire tourne bien
il devrait faire une bonne plus value le
jour où il la revendre à ce sont des
réussites comme celle de patrick qui
très vite ont suscité des vocations chez
d'autres chinois
le problème c'est qu'à chaque fois que
les asiatiques investissent massivement
dans un secteur beaucoup trouvent ça
très louche
maître jean alain michel défend les
intérêts de plusieurs cafetiers chinois
cet avocat doit se battre contre les
accusations dont ses clients font
l'objet je pense qu'il y a chez certains
policiers et peut-être dans le monde
judiciaire
cette idée un peu fausse d'une
résurgence d'une sorte de mafia
c'est une idée qui traîne qui est dans
l'air depuis de très nombreuses années à
paris ça vient de la réussite de la
communauté chinoise du fait que ces gens
prospère et on a le sentiment que ça
c'est pas normal et guangxi pas normal
c'est qu'il y a des origines
frauduleuses pourtant le rachat des bars
tabac pmu est étroitement surveillé par
les autorités
la direction centrale de la police
judiciaire à nanterre il existe même un
service spécialisé celui des courses et
jeux qui enquête sur la respectabilité
des futurs acquéreurs commandant
baillargeon jour mon nom payen donc venu
pour le pmu est la vôtre base ce matin
le commandant dai a reçoit de nouveau
candidat qui souhaite garder l'anonymat
les asiatiques âgé d'une trentaine
d'années qui vont devoir se plier
un vrai petit interrogatoire donc vous
êtes là pour qu'on va sa petite enquête
concernant le pmu a fait une demande d
pmu vous êtes deux frères ses seins donc
vous avez amené des documents qu'on a
demandé dans un premier temps donc on va
en parler au fur à mesure dont il va
d'abord s'assurer de leur identité est
donné à la défense
pour pouvoir vendre des cigarettes donc
c'est pour être français ou au moins un
ressortissant européen
vous êtes nominé wenzhou de nos cités
françaises et prénom votre mère c'est le
cas de ces nouveaux buralistes qui ont
la double nationalité française et
chinoise
j'ai dit la question aussi est ce que
nous tous connu la police ou pas mais
provient avec la police vous non plus
d'accord notez qu'on va vérifier bien
que faisant douter déclaration d'impôts
fiche de paie crédit bancaire
c'est pour tout le monde pareil mais
c'est surtout l'apport personnel qui se
monte à au moins un tiers de la fvr qui
intéresse le commandant de layar ce qui
nous importe c'est la provenance des
fonds bien sûr s'il ya des économies
d'où viennent les économies est ce qu'il
ya une revente de maisons une vente d'un
bien d'un bien
et c est donc les personnes doit nous
apporter les preuves de leurs de la
vente de leurs biens ou de l'origine des
fonds c'est important pour éviter le
blanchiment d'argent et le circuit du
blanchiment d'argent
messieurs mon nom je vais vous
accompagner pour récupérer vos pièces
d'identité et je vous tiens au courant
c'est lors d'une procédure comme celle
ci que l'année dernière
les policiers sont tombés sur une grosse
affaire l'histoire a fait les gros
titres des journaux
un réseau chinois auraient fait main
basse sur une dizaine de pmu de la
région parisienne
derrière ces rachats la police se
demande s'il n'y aurait pas l'argent de
la mafia asiatique après huit mois
d'enquêté
une vingtaine de personnes ont été
arrêtées
tous des français d'origine chinoise
chacun avait investi jusqu'à 280 mille
euros pour le rachat d'un bistrot mais
la police soupçonne que cet argent avait
une origine frauduleuse
c'est martin chapleau qui a soulevé le
lièvre ce qui a mis la puce à l'oreille
du commissaire divisionnaire c'est qu'il
y avait 22 acheteurs différents mais
bizarrement ils avaient tous fait appel
aux mêmes notaire chinois pour prouver
l'origine des fonds on avait vraiment je
dirais des documents copiés collés et
surtout ce qui nous embête est un petit
peu c'est que les requérants étaient
tous des jeunes gens qui avaient des
revenus très faibles et qu'ils étaient
capables d'acheter des établissements à
des prix très élevé de l'ordre de 800
mille euros en réalité tous les
documents étaient des faux
mais ces chinois sont ils pour autant
des agents de la mafia eux disent que
non que cet argent proviendrait de
donation familiale et s'il ya un
problème de papier c'est que par
tradition en chine ce genre de
transaction se faisait oralement à en
croire leurs avocats il n'aurait donc
pas eu d'autre choix que de recourir à
des justificatifs bidon c'est plus
facile en france quand vous avez un
grand père qui vous a fait une donation
ou qui a de l'argent à la caisse
d'epargne qui vous a prêté cet argent
c'est facile d'en justifier quand c'est
le même phénomène se passe en chine
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué d'en
justifier et voilà pourquoi on a choisi
les solutions de facilité
un procès devrait avoir lieu en
attendant les vingt personnes ont été
remises en liberté
elles ont repris leur place derrière les
comptoirs
sauf que cette affaire les a traumatisés
ils disent tous être victime de la
rumeur d'idées toutes faites sur la
communauté chinoise
vous avez envie qu'on voulait dire les
gens comme foyer mafia chinoise c'est
très sec 1/10 temps non mais ça
toutefois ce nom des gens la bouche
c'est à une balade c'est qu'ottawa va
changer quoi voilà qu'on fasse on sait
qu'on ne peut pas changer les préjugés
des gens non pour avoir produit des faux
documents
il risque jusqu'à cinq ans de prison
avec sursis
il n'empêche si elle est semé d'embûches
pour certains l'acquisition d'un bistrot
et pour d'autres un formidable tremplin
de réussite sociale
c'était en février dernier à belleville
à l'occasion du nouvel an chinois
il y à 7 ans personne ne connaissait
patrick chan
depuis qu'il est à la tête de son bar
tabac c'est une vraie sommité dans le
quartier jours mais rover cette année
c'est même lui qui a organisé le défilé
et il est le seul à se permettre de
pouvoir faire la mise à madame le maire
des patrons de bars chinois comme lui il
y en a aujourd'hui des centaines et des
centaines en france on va commencer par
l'ouverture des yeux d'une allemand en
quatre ans ils ont créé 4000 emplois
bien qu'en région parisienne